وانتم تستوردون غازكم من قطر؟
نعم فرائحة غازي بلحاف شبوة
بهذا السؤال. وقعتم عقود بيع غاز
لفرنسا فمن اين لكم بهذا الغاز
اليمنية تملأ المكان. فلتراجع
حساباتكم فالتاريخ لا يرحم احد.
والحكومة اليمنية بشكل مباشر.
بينما يحذر الغرب من السلاح
لابرام الاتفاق في وقت قريب.
الامارات تطلق الدفعة الثانية من
المليار وجبة لمتضرري السيول في
السودان. عن اي كرم نتحدث ويا
دعوة رسمية للمغرب لحضور القمة
العربية المقبلة. الخارجية
والتطورات. مبعوث جزائري خاص يصل
العاصمة المغربية الرباط لتقديم
الامريكية لايران لن نقبل باتفاق
سيء ولدينا شروط وليس هناك فرصة
في سماه حياكة المؤامرات على
تركيا. واكد ان بلاده لن تتوانى
مستنقع بحسب تعبيره. تعبير
اردوجان جاء بسبب انزال الاسلحة
يجري وراء الكواليس ليحل بالعراق
الكثير من الكوابيس وتحليق مستمر
للجن فنون لتتوالى بعدها تجارب
المجنون زعيم كوريا الشمالية كيم
الدول الاوروبية. يا للعجب! في
ايطاليا كانت هذه الفتاة معجبة
ورطة كيم الى ورطة ابناء العم
سام. وبعد ان ترك الميكروفون
الامريكية الى كوريا الجنوبية
لاجراء مناورات عسكرية المشتركة.
عبارات سب مشينة بحق الامريكان
منها الاوغاد والحقراء لقد وقع
الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي في ورطة
الان. فما رأيكم كيف سيرد
الشرق بحسب جارته الجنوبية. هذه
التجربة تسبق زيارة نائبة الرئيس
بجورجيا ميلوني هزة سياسية تسقط
دور الرجل لتأخذ هذا الدور في
الهجوم. اصحاب العيون الضيقة
يوسعونها قليلا ويبدأون الهجوم.
محتمل ووضع الرجل مبلغ مائة
مليون دولار لذلك. اوروبا تحكمه
بالذعر. ها هي اوروبا تتحول الى
حكم النساء فهل فشل الرجال حقا?
امريكيون سابقون بحسب تقارير
امريكية وهي على الاراضي
سفينتين بحريتين صينيتين اخريين
واربع سفن بحرية روسية بما في
الامريكية معروفة باسم القاطع
كانت تقوم بدورية روتينية في بحر
للقتال في دومبس الاوكرانية بعد
نفيه لسنوات اي وجود علاقة تربطه
قبل النواب في خطوة قال عنها
الحلبوسي نفسه في لقاء تليفزيوني
سياسيين فان هذا التصويت لا
يتعدى كونه اجراء شكليا. كل ذلك
في كافة انحاء اليونان خطر على
اليونانيين وقد تحولها الى
بتأسيسه مجموعة فاغنر شبه
العسكرية عام الفين واربعة عشر
بها. اليوم تدور مجموعة جديدة
اسمها موزرت اسسها ضباط وجنود
التواضع يا بوتين? طب بوتين.
لطالما تساءل العالم عن مؤسس
عن الدفاع عن حقوقها ومصالحها
بكافة الوسائل المتاحة. وان ما
الرجال. والتضخم الاقتصادي
وارتفاع الاسعار يصيب مجتمعاتهم
واوروبا سينقذكم? لا لن يفعل بل
ستراوحون مكانكم. هكذا قالها
النووي فهو اول الخائفين من
استخدامه ايضا. لكن كل ذلك يتوقف
لكرم الامارات السخي. ولكن مهلا
فنفس هذه الصناديق دخلت اليمن
الطراد لم يكن بمفرده حيث ابحرت
على بعد ستة وثمانين ميلا شمال
القناصة على نفقته الخاصة لحماية
الجزيرة التايوانية من غزو صيني
جزيرة كيسكا في الاسكا في التاسع
عشر من سبتمبر. وهناك تم اكتشاف
في الجزر السلاح في بحر ايجا من
قبل اليونانيين. الاحداث
النساء. التي لا تنطفئ انطفأت
انوارها تحت حكم قادتها من
تركيا تتوعد. هل تظنون ان دعم
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
وكالة الامن القومي الامريكية.
وعلى مدى سنوات طالبت السلطات
اتطالب بالاحترام وانت تمتلك
اخطر سلاح في العالم? ما كل هذا
وصف بالحشود العسكرية الاجنبية
ذات المظهر الاحتلالي المنتشرة
فلما يتلقى العراق كل هذه
الطعنات والجروح بدون توقف.
سياسية خانقة وفي ظل معيشة ضنكا.
النبض العراقي لا يتوقف. بينما
وسبعين اجنبيا بينهم ادوارد
سنودن ضابط المخابرات الامريكية
الاوساط السياسية العراقية بطرح
استقالته من منصبه للتصويت من
انها جاءت من دون التشاور مع
حلفائه بشأنها لكن وبحسب مراقبين
المبعوث الامريكي الى اليمن. من
المهم ان يلتقي الحوثيون
لتظهر في النهاية انها مواد
منتهية الصلاحية لنتقدم للامارات
جاسوسا ام انها لعبة من الامن
الفيدرالي الهدف منها اللعب
الرئيس التركي اردوغان مضيفا ان
اليونان ستدفع ثمنا باهظا لدورها
الامريكان على هذا التسريب?
الجسد العراقي يتألم. في ظل ازمة
كيم لا يتوقف ولا يخاف تهديدات
واشنطن. وهنا الجارة الجنوبية من
سابقا كان رئيس مجلس النواب
العراقي محمد الحلبوسي قد فاجأ
شهادة جامعية. ميلوني زعيمة حزب
اخوان ايطاليا اليمينية المتطرفة
باعادة سنودن ليوجه محاكم جنائية
بتهمة التجسس وسرقة ممتلكات
مفتوحا دون قصد. واثناء حديثه مع
مستشاريه لتتسرب من ضمن حديثه
والمثيرة للجدل هي اول امرأة
تحكم ايطاليا. صواريخ الغضب.
في صغرها بموسوليني وعملت مربية
اطفال وساقية بحانة ولم تحصل على
عواقب كارثية على روسيا.
الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤها
محترف. بوتين يوجه ضربة لواشنطن
ويمنح الجنسية الروسية اثنين
وبعد ان ترأست ليزيتش حكومة
بريطانيا ها هي ايطاليا تصعد
الامريكي كاميلا هاريسليسول.
وتتزامن مع وصول حاملة الطائرات
ياباني وفي اليوم التالي مسؤول
بالحكومة اليابانية انه تم
لطائرات ايرانية وتارة تركية.
والهدف اقليم كردستان العراق.
امريكا ومنح حق اللجوء في روسيا
بعد ان سرب ملفات سرية عام الفين
بك? اما في تايوان فيقوم رجل
اعمال تايواني بتجهيز جيش من
شركة فاغنر. اليك الجواب من
المؤسس بذاته. رجل الاعمال
الحرب النووية هنا ياتي الكرم
الحاتم مع اوكرانيا. لتعلن
جونج اون. جديده هذه المرة اطلاق
صاروخ باليستي قصير المدى في بحر
الاحترام اولا? حيث اكد بوتين
اهمية احترام الغرب لروسيا.
تملكه التي تعتبر علاجا مؤقتا
للمصابين باشعاعات نووية خوفا من
حكومية لكن هل يعيده بوتين يا
ترى? الجواب معلوم لديكم.
مؤكدة انها كارثة على من
يستخدمها كما هي على الاخرين. من
مؤكدا ان الامر ليس خدعة. فعن اي
خدعة تتحدث. وعلى وقع التهديد
حيث قال خفر السواحل الامريكي ان
سفينة بيعة لخفر السواحل
الروسي المقرب من الكريملين
والملقب بطباخ بوتين. يعترف
بيورينج عثرت على طراد صاروخي
موجه من الصين. لكن اتضح ان
ذلك مدمرة فهل تعمل الصين كما
يقول المثل تغدى به قبل ان يتعشى
وثلاثة عشر. كشفت عن عمليات
مراقبة محلية ودولية نفذتها
الاوكرانية. فهل نشهد صراعا بين
فاغنر وموزارت? الصين تبدأ
هنا مصيدة الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي تعلن قبضها على قنصل
سياسة الهمس سرا. وعلى لسان
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
واشنطن اذا? ومن الاسرار
اللوجستية الى الحرب الجاسوسية.
جيك سوليفان ادارة الرئيس جو
بايدن حذرت الكرملين سرا من ان
كرم امريكي ام رغبة في اطالة
الحرب. ومن السياسة العلنية الى
سيردون بشكل حاسم. لكن ان كان
هذا الامر سرا فلماذا كشفت
السابق والمتهم بالتجسس عمره
تسعة وثلاثون عاما. هرب من
الاراضي الامريكية هذه المرة.
المجنون يواصل هوايته والعراق
فليجرب. ودول اوروبا ترد بهذا
الاجراء. بينما اتخذت امريكا
بالفعل اطلاق سراح القنصل ليدور
في اذهاننا سؤال. هل كان فعلا
طريقا اخر. فما هو يا ترى وطباخ
بوتين يعترف بما انكره سابقا.
الى منع اسلحة نووية لدى من
وصفهم بالجيران المعادين مثل
هكذا ضحكت موسكو وقالت الاسلحة
النووية ليست خدعة. والمكذب
على ما سيقرره بوتين. فماذا
ستقرر ايها الدب الروسي?
باعصاب اليابانيين. ضربة معلم.
كش ملك. نعم بوتين لاعب شطرنج
اي استخدام للاصل النووية في
الحرب في اوكرانيا ستكون له
الادارة الامريكية ان لدى واشنطن
خطة للتعامل مع الاسلحة النووية
الروسي رعت دول اوروبية الى
اخراج مخزون مادة اليود الذي
واشنطن عن مساعدات لكييف بقيمة
اثني عشر مليار دولار يا الهي
فيدف ويوضح ان موسكو سترد في حال
تجاوز اي تهديد الخط الاحمر.
لروسيا الحق في استخدام الاسلحة
النووية اذا لزم الامر بينما ترد
اوكرانيا التي يسيطر عليها
الناتو وفق تعبيره. واضاف ان
مجلس الامن القومي الروسي ديمتري
ميدفيديف يقول ان روسيا ستسعى
الجريح يترنح. اما الجزائر فتقوم
بامر غريب مع المغرب. فما الذي
فهل يكفون عن ذلك? الخطر يقترب.
التصريحات الهجومية والعدائية لا
يعرف جيدا ماذا يحدث. هنا زلزال
سياسي ياتي على لسان نائب رئيس
يجري وابناء زايد يواصلون تقديم
هداياهم كما يفعلونها في اليمن
تتوقف. الاجواء مكهربة. لا احد
يسأل ما الذي يجري لان الجميع
التحدي. فيما الصين تطلق رسالة
للولايات المتحدة لكن بالقرب من
المواجهة ضد روسيا بهذه العملية.
النساء يحكمن اوروبا وتركيا تعلن
وبوتين يوجه ضربة استخباراتية
مؤلمة لواشنطن. واليابان تدخل خط